why was it important for you to come
here today to be here your first time
here why did you want to come along
why does it have been newly renovated
yeah and Ana I'd never connected with
this part of my life never no no no no
like I used to come to South Carolina
every summer but I didn't come see this
building I don't even know the building
existed I think I didn't go I think I
went to the church when I was little I
think it's just important to me now
because I have kids myself now and you
know I'm going through a lot of changes
professionally no you know so I just
kind of want to give like a context of
like and also because it has father sort
of thinking about what might be possible
what do you mean what do you mean so
much you you know outside of my show
business like man I could build
something you know I could help I don't
know I could do something I don't know
what I don't know what I could do but
with great power comes great
responsibility
and so if you would please join me in
welcoming Dave Chappelle home again
oh thank you
you know um I speak for a living and I'm
a little nervous today I wanted to say
Thank You mr. president and thank you
Bishop green and and thank everyone Alan
University for hosting me today because
it feels special right when I when I
think of this great grandfather that
I've heard about in my life but never
never actually touched his legacy so
it's like the product of his loins
coming to meet the product of his work
and and it's a it's an important day for
me personally and I know a lot of you
guys are students and I just want to
tell you I'm the first person in my
family to not go to college
and as the president has told you I've
done outstanding in spite of that
but one thing I did want to say one
thing today just made me think about for
all the things that I've done I'm most
renowned for what I didn't do
I've made decisions in my career that a
lot of people have called insane 2004 at
fifty million dollar deal on the table
and in a crisis of conscience flips the
table over and walked away
went to South Africa everyone said I was
running away from the money that is not
true in fact I still want that money the
idea that I wanted to just share with
you guys is the idea that sometimes you
do what you think is best
whether anybody understand it or not I
heard a story about my father was
someone told me he used to do statistics
for a company in DC the company did
statistics for started doing business
with the South African government so he
quit his job it's caused a lot of
problems between his him and his wife
it's hard for a man when he can't
provide for his family the way he wants
to and he suffered through it and a
generation later when I had my crisis of
conscience I was able to go to a free
South Africa and get away from the idea
that what you do in your lifetime
informs the generations that comes after
he was something like keep thinking
about something that it's so much bigger
than just ourselves and today I'm
standing in front of you guys and I know
you guys like those I know you're bored
but I see family of mine in the front
row that I some who I've never met and I
just realized how how old all of us are
connected there my great-grandfather
built something more substantial than
buildings he built a community and he
built more importantly than a community
he built a way
you know so I'm very grateful very
grateful hello police
I was something like you saying over
like so this is what black people talk
about
[Applause]
yeah
I just want I just want I just want you
guys remember you know that right now
there's this thing with where ethics
aren't what they used to be this idea
that people are trying to replace the
ideas of good and bad with better or
worse and that is incorrect you got keep
your ethics intact because good and bad
is a compass that helps you find a way
in a person that only does was better or
worse is the easiest type of person to
control they are a mouse in a maze that
just finds the cheese but the one who
knows about good and bad will realize
that he's in a maze so that being said I
just hope that all of you guys transcend
whatever you see is your obstacles and
that you live outstanding lives and that
you stay connected to your communities
because you have so much power there and
that you grow your communities and you
diverse fire communities and that you
don't let anybody anybody tell you you
can't or to be afraid it's okay to be
afraid because you can't be brave or
courageous without fear the idea of
being courageous is that even though
you're scared you just do the right
thing anyway so in 2004 I walked away
from 50 million dollars and in November
I made a deal for 60 million dollars so
although I am NOT the most famous
comedian of my time I would like to know
what their great grandfather's dead I'm
I'm very proud today thank you very much